[Music]
all right
the family is out to go bike riding well
at least tiffin tiff and isaac are going
to go bike riding
busting out the bikes no i'm not going
to take my bike i am going to
run and try and keep up with them bikes
hey guys so good morning
when is the ass so we woke up early-ish
to come back to isaac's eye doctor
because he has another appointment
and if you guys remember we talked about
how isaac has these crt
lenses that are kind of like retainers
for your eyeballs so he doesn't have to
wear
any sort of like eye correctiveness
throughout the day so
no contacts no glasses and a lot of you
guys were actually curious
and wanted to learn more about what crt
lenses are
because like like me in the past you
guys have never heard about these lenses
so we're actually going to be talking to
isaac's eye doctor about them
and learning more about what crt lenses
are all about
and also hear from isaac and see what
his
experience with them have been he's
still waking up so
excuse isaac for a little bit you still
have your bed head going on
hi doctor how are you
you're ready to get those lenses checked
yeah yeah
all right so this is dr eric toe here at
lumen optometric
and he's going to be talking to us about
this boy's
lenses right here did you bring him yep
nice all right so we got the lenses and
we're going to get
educated so this is optically how
corneal reshaping or ortho k lenses work
compared to standard lenses okay so
when we focus here and when i draw this
shape
this is think of this as the cornea this
is the clear window of your eye
looking straight up towards the ceiling
here okay and so when you wear let's say
normal contacts right normal contacts
just drape over the eye
yeah they're soft and um there's really
no
no they just conform to the eye
essentially now when it's corneal
reshaping or ortho k
lenses the lenses have a more unique
shape and so i call it
a volcanic shape here okay so you'll see
these two humps in this this specific
area
and so when you sleep in this lens what
happens is
that there's there's a force there's a
negative pressure force so it's actually
a
pull force okay so it pulls in this
direction and it pulls in this direction
here
there's no pushing um when you have a
lens that pushes it's unhealthy and some
patients do have issues which we'll talk
about later but
when you have a properly designed lens
it's always negative pressure there's
never any push okay
and so what happens what's what's unique
about how this works is that
in terms of the cornea the cells will
actually migrate to the area of pull
and they'll migrate to this area and
they'll
migrate to this region as well and then
what happens is that there's a resultant
change in the shape of the cornea so the
cornea actually
takes on this the slightly volcanic
shape as well so
it's a little bit thicker in this region
and it's a little bit
thicker in this region and for all our
patients like for isaac too isaac was
myopic
otherwise known as nearsighted and when
you when if any of you
folks watching the video are myopic or
near side if you touch your lenses your
glasses lenses
you'll notice it's thicker at the edges
compared to the center and so the way we
always designate
lenses for patients who are myopic is
it looks like this it's sort of like a
sideways hourglass so you know it's
thicker on the edge here and thicker
here
and optically that's how it cancels out
the prescription so essentially what
we're doing is we're building that
correction into the eye that's what
allows isaac to see
clear uh every morning once he takes the
lenses out and
he sees clear for the rest of the day
yeah so i actually had a dm
from one of you guys asking me whether
or not dr tow has discussed with us
the negative side effects that could
potentially happen because there was
someone in my dance who told me about
her experience how she had crt lenses
growing up during throughout her
childhood but then when she entered her
adulthood
she was notified that those lenses
ended up like eating down her corn yet
so she
ended up having a negative experience
with crt lenses so what are
some thoughts that you might have as to
why that might have happened to her
and is this an actual effect that can
happen
to anyone like to isaac for example like
will we find out later when he's an
adult that
his cornea is depleted uh when it comes
to this question it goes back to
how this how you design the software how
you design the lenses with the software
and also how you monitor your patients
as well so if we go back to
a really quick whiteboard when you
consider how the lenses are shaped again
right so really exaggerated here
again you're creating negative pressure
here and negative pressure here
and the cornea pretty much sits right
underneath it the
thing is is that these lenses there's
always a cushion
of tears okay there's never a point
where the lens where there's never a
point where the lens is supposed to
actually
touch the eye because if the the back
surface of that lens touches the front
surface of your cornea you'll definitely
have an abrasion
okay and so most likely that's probably
what happened for some of our patients
we always or for all of our patients we
always monitor how their eyes are doing
by looking in and i have isaac come back
quarterly to make sure everything's
healthy i think even for tiffany she
she didn't she wasn't aware of um ortho
k crt until somebody else had told her
yeah and so a lot of patients aren't
aware of it and there's a lot of
potential for keeping
eyes healthy with it i mean this isn't
the only way to keep eyes healthy
whenever we have a patient we always
fight to make sure that they're they're
healthy and that they love the
experience because most parents don't
know and so when somebody
performs earth okay improperly then then
that type of news spreads and it does it
does
kids kids like isaac a disservice it
does future kids whose parents
who who find that one i mean for every
thousand kids who are happy there might
be
one child who saw a provider that wasn't
taking very good care
and and the news of that one tends to
spread like wildfire
yeah so um i always fight to make sure
our kids are
and take them have their eyes well taken
care of so that
their eyes are healthy and that future
kids don't don't find this
this news and their parents don't tend
to ruminate on it yeah that's true
because
we actually heard from isaac's dentist
about his daughter
doing crt lenses and we were like what
is this because isaac had already been
tired
of using content or no not contacts he
had been tired of using glasses he was
interested in getting contacts but then
once his dentist
brought this up we were like oh that
sounds way better you have to wear
contacts throughout the days only at
night we started treatment back in april
so it's already been more than a whole
year that you've been doing this
honestly it feels nice i remember when i
was little when i had
clear vision i remember one day i looked
into the projector at school
and that's when it started getting
blurry it's pretty nice to have that
same experience
but older and getting to see the road
name from far away without wearing
anything on my face yeah back like when
you were really little and you had clear
vision huh yeah
those are really nice the lenses i have
now is very comfortable
that you have now the lenses that you
have now are very comfortable
because i can't really feel them
sometimes
so yeah it's like my regular eye because
i know in the beginning when we first
started this treatment
you were having some issues with the
comfortableness
comfortability of your lenses yeah
comfort
yeah yeah i think for isaac i mean you
were saying clear even though it was a
little uncomfortable in the beginning
though
from under a call and so optically he
was he was well protected but some of
our patients their eyes are a little
more sensitive so i just have to alter
the fit
i mean when you're when you're taking a
custom scan you're taking a custom scan
of
essentially it's a soft soft tissue and
so there's assumptions that are made
there and for some patients the
assumptions are really spot on sometimes
they're a little bit more
they're a little off and so we just have
to accommodate for it and so
once once we're aware of the issue then
we correct it and now we're good
yeah and another thing that really sold
me for crt lenses was when we first came
in
dr toe was telling us about how over
time
these types of lenses end up maintaining
the health
of isaac's eyeballs over time your eyes
end up getting elongated
because those lenses are over correcting
your eyes
so which means like throughout time your
vision is
technically getting worse right normally
yeah
yeah normally normally if we hadn't done
anything and if isaac were just
continuing normal glasses or contacts
his eyes would have kept growing yeah
and every time it's
it grows it actually gets less healthy
yeah because the
there's the there's the light think of
the eye as a camera there's
essentially it's almost like film on the
inside it's the retina
and that is the same size as your eyes
growing the problem is
as your eye grows that retina has to
stretch and so it doesn't like being
stretched
all right so we got to learn a lot from
dr toe about crt lenses
and myopia management and if you guys
are interested in checking out dr toe
you can check out the website
down in the description below
lumenoptometric.com
and if you're not local to la you can
also check out his website and then
there's also references or resources
there where you guys can find
an eye doctor closest to you
so thank you so much dr toe for having
us appreciate the educational lesson
and we'll be coming back for isaac's
checkups
all right now we're going to go home and
make some video games
i'm gonna play some video games spend
some time outside yeah right
spend some time outside right
he tried teaching me the other day and
it was a fail
but you can try teaching me again yeah
maybe i could write to the mailbox
yes yeah away from video games right
that's right yeah yeah
more time outside of this diamond doors
more on this rimstick thing sounds great
all right so we're home now yeah yeah we
got some starbucks
and then isaac's favorite would you get
vanilla frappe i got the vanilla frappe
with
caramel and whipped cream vanilla bean
vanilla bean and then a double smoked
bacon sugar
oh nice and i got
ice chai latte baby my favorite i always
get it
and i also got the bacon egg bites
not sponsored by the way it seems like
this is just sponsored by starbucks now
at this point
but it's not but anyway i didn't really
get to eat anything because we
i woke up and we had to go to the
doctors true
yeah well we're digging my boy a couple
days ago
i saw him he was using the kitty litter
and he looked like he was on timeout
because he was downstairs
looking into the corner i'm sweaty
he's so weird why are you putting
yourself in timeout dude
look at that he's doing it again staring
at the wall
hey dude we're talking about you you
look smack
he looks mad why does he look so mad
casey's downstairs and he's
having a meeting so technically
i should be a lot quieter all right the
family is out
to go bike riding well at least tiffin
tiff and isaac are gonna go bike riding
busting out the bikes no i'm not gonna
take my bike i am gonna
run and try and keep up with them bikes
yeah i'm trying to get back into shape i
have
gotten a little bit thicker around the
waist area
so the mission now is to get into
summer beach body shape in the middle
of summer i'm gonna run while you guys
uh
bike ride i wonder if i can keep up with
you guys all right we're starting
right here they're gone
i'm starting to think this is a bad idea
i am not up to shape
to keep up with them riding
their bikes but okay
thanks for slowing down oh my goodness
oh my goodness
this clip is only a minute long i'm
dying
holy crap
this is a general mistake okay i should
have probably worked my way up
to doing this but this is literally
the second day of running oh my god i'm
my family
i've lost my family right now here
oh
[Music]
that's so funny because you guys are
like cruising i'm
okay nice yeah cause like i'm like you
guys are cruising
and i'm like supposed to be jogging but
i'm like sprinting
okay
[Music]
don't wait for me guys i'll be okay
[Music]